[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend bei mir ist Christin Otto
schaut später unter anderem zur Fußball
naationalmannschaft in die USA und beach
volleyball WM guten Abend und hier sind
unsere Themen an diesem
Donnerstag die Hamas im Visier Israel
zieht weitere Truppen am Gazastreifen
zusammen währendess hat die lufthanser
begonnen deutsche aus Israel zu
evakuieren gaslieferrand
Wirtschaftspartner Unterstützer der
Hamas der Emir von Qatar ist in Berlin
ein politischer Drahtseilakt für den
Kanzler und kein Schutz um jeden Preis
Wölfe die zum Problem werden sollen
leichter geschossen werden
können wir beleuchten auch heute die
nahosteskalationen aus verschiedenen
perspektiv
im politischen Berlin rückten heute alle
zusammen große Solidarität mit Israel
und ein Verbot von Hamas und
Unterstützern im Gazastreifen ist man
wegen israelischer Gegenschläge fast
nirgendwo mehr sicher und dem nach wie
vor schwergeschockten Israel bereiten
sie die nächsten Militäraktionen vor l
walpot
berichtet israelische Luftangriffe auch
heute auf Ziele in Gaza mehr als 300.000
Menschen haben nach UN-Angaben
inzwischen ihr Zuh Hause verloren die
Zahl der Toten und der Verwundeten
steigt die Bewohner sind
verzweifelt unser Haus hatte sechs
Etagen wir gingen gestern schlafen dann
stürzte plötzlich das ganze Haus ein
sieben Menschen sind jetzt tot und viele
im Krankenhaus wie es den geht weiß ich
nicht jenseits des Gazastreifens setzt
die israelische Armee ihren
truppenaumarsch fort ein Einmarsch in
Gaza das Wissen diese soldatengt große
Risiken auch für die von Hamas
entführten
Geiseln derzeit haben wir 97 Familien
identifiziert deren Angehörige entführt
wurden wir wissen wie groß die
Erwartungen dieser Menschen
sind Erwartungen die Familien
französischer Geiseln heute formulierten
von Samuel Ben Davids Schwester Celin
z.B fit Samstag jedes
Lebenszeichen wir
wollenäsidces oder dorthin verschleppt
wurdenuszuholen Regierungschef netanahu
empfing unterdessen US Außenminister
Blinken der betonte noch einmal die
amerikanische Solidarität mit dem
schwergeprüften Verbündeten versprach
weitere militärische Hilfe und wandte
sich inirekt auch an den
Iran wir haben eine glasklare Warnung an
alle staatlichen und nichtstaatlichen
Gegner die glauben sie könnten die
aktuelle Krise für einen Angriff auf
Israel nutzen lassen Sie es
israel hat die volle Unterstützung der
USA blinken dessen Stiefvater ein
Überlebender der scho war traf
anschließend mit Überlebenden der Hamas
Terrorattacken
zusammen Michael beverunge ist heute
Abend für uns in Tel Aviv in einer
bewegenden Szenerie was sehen wir da
hinter dir
Michael ja ich stehe hier im Zentrum von
telaviv am diesengorfplatz das ist so
etwas wie das von Tel Aviv h sind
spontan hunderte Menschen hergekommen um
ihre Trauer zu bekundnen sie haben ich
weiß nicht Taus Kerzen aufgestellt für
die Opfer ich denke das ist auch das
Hauptanliegen von US- Außenminister
blinken Empathie und Trauer mit den
Opfern zu bekunden aber darüber hinaus
auch konkrete Solidarität und die
Warnung die er z.B in Richtung Iran oder
Syrien ausgesprochen hat die ist ganz
konkret unterlegt mit Waffenlieferung
die an Israel gehen aber auch mit der
flugzeugträgerflotte die Mittelmeer
aufmarschiert um notfalls einzugreifen
zugleich das muss man aber auch ganz
deutlich sagen hat Israel hat blinken
Israel gewarnt er sagte genau das
unterscheidet uns demokratische
Gesellschaften von Terroristen dass wir
humanitäre Werte haben wir müssen
aufpassen dass wir selbst bei der
Kriegsführung diese humanitären Werte
beachten und wenn möglich zivile Opfer
vermeiden in der Praxis allerdings das
weiß auch blinken ist das zum Teil graue
Theorie und lässt nicht immer konkret
umsetzen wie die hohen Opferzahlen auch
in Gaza zeigen danke schön nach telaviv
Michael
beverunge jedes hamasmglied ist ein
toter Mann Israel werde die Hamas
zerquetschen und zerstören das sagte
israels Ministerpräsident Netanyahu nach
den Attacken der Hamas seitdem fliegt
das israelische Militär schwere
Luftangriffe auf den Gazastreifen das
Gebiet gehört zu den am dichtesten
besiedelten der Welt mehr zur Lage zur
Situation und Status dieses speziellen
palästinensergebietes von Volker
dutsek Gaza Stadt nach sech Tagen Krieg
der drohenfugzeugt die Zerstörungen der
dichtbewohnten Hauptstadt der
Gazastreifen selbst ist 40 km lang und
bis zu 14 km breit und damit halb so
groß wie Hamburg hier leben rund 2,2
Millionen Menschen jeder Zweite ist
Flüchtling und jünger als 18 Jahre ein
Großteil der hier lebenden ist von
Lebensmittelhilfen abhängig die Region
steht seit 2007 unter der Verwaltung der
Hamas was übersetzt heißt islamische
Widerstandsbewegung die
radikalislamische palästinensergruppe
wird vom Westen als Terrororganisation
eingestuft die Hamas fordert die
Vernichtung des Staates Israel Israel
sit Gaza als feindliches Gebiet und hat
die Zugänge
abgeriegelt die Hamas ist gleichzeitig
politische Partei
Terrororganisation und Soziales
Hilfswerk weil sie schulen Kindergärten
und Hospitäler betreibt ist die Hamas
stark im sozialen System verankert diese
sozialen Einrichtungen werden nach
Einschätzung Israels oft als
Schutzschilde benutzt um Waffen und
Munitionslager zu tarnen oder die
Eingänge zu dem weit verzweigten
Tunnelsystem unter der Stadt nach vielen
Treffern sind nach Angaben der Vereinten
Nationen fast
340.000 Zivilisten in den ersten Tagen
des Krieges aus ihren Wohnungen
geflüchtet jetzt zur NATO nach Brüssel
die Botschaft der Verteidigungsminister
ist geschlossen und klar bei ihrem
Treffen heute sichern Sie dem
zugeschalteten israelischen
Verteidigungsminister Galland ihre
Solidarität zu sowie militärische Hilfe
Deutschland will Israel mit bis zu zwei
Kampfdrohnen unterstützen und prüft die
Lieferung von Munition für
Kriegsschiffe tausende Bundesbürger
versuchen Israel gerade zu verlassen am
Flughafen in Aviv spielten sich teils
chaotische Szenen ab dabei wurde auch
das Krisenmanagement deutscher Behörden
kritisiert vier lufthansermaschinen
brachten am Nachmittag die ersten
deutschen zurück zwei sind inzwischen in
München und Frankfurt gelandet Christoph
desterell
berichtet Flughafen Tel Aviv es sieht
aus wie Urlaubsanfang oder Ende es ist
aber ernster denn wenn auch nur indirekt
alle hier haben die wachsende Gefahr
irgendwie zu spüren bekommen gestern
Abend hatten wir auch im Norden ein
Luftalarm war im Bunker das war ein
fehleralarm letztlich aber natürlich ist
man angespannt die eigenen Leute
heimholen während manche Länder dafür
Militärmaschinen schicken hat das
Auswärtige Amt die lufthanser beauftragt
acht Sonderflüge an zwei Tagen sind
organisiert es gibt eine Hotline und
viel ratlose Wut ich habe gestern
ungefähr 300 mal versucht diese Hotline
zu erreichen ich bin nicht durchgekommen
5 Stunden lang habe ich ja versucht
irgendwann um 3 Uhr morgens habe ich
dann halt eine Verbindung nach Südafrika
bekommen und das war alles auf Englisch
plötzlich war die Verbindung dann weg
etwa 5000 deutsche wollen raus aus der
krisenzone es auf die Flüge nach
Frankfurt oder München schaffen mit
Hochdruck arbeite man alle Anfragen ab
erklärt die lufthanser und entschuldigt
sich auf X vormals Twitter trotz
erhöhter Kapazitäten lassen sich
Wartezeiten jedoch leider nicht
vermeiden gegen 5:30 Uhr landet die
erste Maschine in Frankfurt mit den gut
300 70 deutschen Staatsangehörigen die
irgendwie Tickets bekommen haben Inge
Rocco wartet auf ihren Mann der auf
Pilgerreise war Tage hat sie gebankt ich
bin einfach froh dass meine Kinder hier
sind dass sie auch ihren Papa
Wiedersehen weil ich war einfach sehr
sehr schlimm auch für meine Kinder und
die sind einfach nur froh wenn wir den
im Arm haben glückliches Ende in
Frankfurt für die ersten Heimkehrer aber
viel mehr müssen noch in Israel
[Musik]
warten im Bundestag da gab es heute
keinen Streit das Parlament rückte
zusammen einstimmig folgte man einem
gemeinsamen Antrag von Ampel und Union
größtmögliche Solidarität mit Israel und
das Verbot für die Hamas und ihre
Unterstützer in Deutschland aktiv zu
sein mehr dazu jetzt von Daniel
ponzen Solidarität mit Israel hier der
Botschafter und scharfe Verurteilung der
Hamas sie standen im Zentrum vieler
Redebeiträge heute zu allererst in der
Regierungserklärung des Kanzlers tief
sei die gemeinsame Trauer um die Opfer
der barbarischen Taten groß die Sorge um
die verschleppten Geiseln unsere zweite
große Sorge gilt der regionalen
Dimension des Konflikts wir haben bisher
zwar keine handfesten Belege dafür dass
Iran diesen feigen Angriff der Hamas
konkret und operativ unterstützt hat
aber uns allen ist klar ohne iranische
Unterstützung über die letzten Jahre
wäre die Hamas zu diesen präzedenzlosen
Angriffen auf israelisches Territorium
nicht fähig gewesen zudem kündigte
Scholz an die Hamas in Deutschland zu
verbieten genau wie das Netzwerk samidun
das jüngst für Demos mobilisierte auf
denen der Terror in Israel gefeiert
wurde ein solches Verbot forderte der
Antrag der ampelfraktion und der Union
ebenso wie die Schließung des
islamischen Zentrums Hamburg wie unter
anderem Oppositionsführer März betonte
der mit Blick auf die drohende
Ausweitung des Konflikts hervorhop Ben
gon Israels erster Premierminister hat
einmal gesagt das Schicksal Israel
hängt von zwei Dingen ab seiner Stärke
und seiner
Gerechtigkeit wir wünschen dem Staat
Israel dass er sein
Selbstverteidigungsrecht eben mit Stärke
und Gerechtigkeit ausübt die
Unterstützung des Deutschen Bundestages
kann sich Israel dabei sicher sein kurz
danach ging es für Olaf Scholz zurück
ins Kanzleramt wo er lange geplanten
aber auch sehr umstrittenen Besuch
empfingen ja ein umstrittener Besuch
aber in dieser dramatischen Lage sei es
unverantwortlich nicht alle Kontakte zu
nutzen die helfen können so
Bundeskanzler Scholz in seiner
Regierungserklärung damit meinte er eben
auch den Emir von katter der wegen einer
gemeinsamen Energiepartnerschaft heute
in Berlin war Katar zählt zu den
wichtigsten Unterstützern der
Terrororganisation Hamas das Kanzleramt
hofft auf Hilfe etwa bei der Befreiung
von Geiseln unter denen sich auch
deutsche
befinden wir gehen nach Berlin zu Diana
Zimmermann Diana ein schwieriger Termin
nach allem was bislang bekannt ist was
lässt sich über den Besuch sagen ja das
war eine notwendige diplomatische
Verrenkung eigentlich wollten Kanzler
und emia über den gasdeal und
Investitionen in Deutschland reden das
kam nun anders es gab nach dem Treffen
keine Pressekonferenz aber es wurde über
die Situation in Israel und insbesondere
die der Geiseln in Gaza gesprochen
Scholz soll ihre sofortige Befreiung
gefordert und klar gemacht haben die
Verantwortung für die Geiseln dieege
alleine bei der Hamas tatsächlich ist
Katar einer der wichtigsten Unterstützer
für die Hamas und hat Milliarden in den
gazaastifen investiert die Regierung in
Doha macht allein Israel für die
Terrorangriffe der Hamas verantwortlich
wegen der Zitat ständigen Verletzungen
der Rechte des palästinensischen Volkes
die Museen des Landes wurden in den
Farben der palästinensischen Flagge
angeleuchtet sehr viel konträrer als
zwischen Deutschland und Qatar scheint
es also nicht zu gehen und doch nimmt
Qatar in dem Konflikt zwischen Israel
und der Hamas eine Mittlerrolle ein und
Israel das hat Scholz ja betont war über
das Treffen informiert wenn es
irgendjemanden gelingt die 150 Geiseln
darunter fünf Deutsche aus der Gewalt
der Hamas herauszu verhandeln dann wohl
dem Emir von Qatar der Kanzler hat
angekündigt mit ihm in Kontakt zu
bleiben es bleibt also ein ratsalakt
Danke nach Berlin Diana und wir machen
das anderem weiter besonders viele
Menschen fliehen gerade nach Europa auch
mit dem Ziel Deutschland Städte und
Kommunen klagen über die vielen
geflüchteten die trotz Wohnungsnot
untergebracht und trotz Lehrermangels
integriert werden müssen was also tun um
die Migration zu begrenzen gestern legte
die Bundesregierung einen Plan vor heute
beraten darüber die Ministerpräsidenten
der Länder Klaus
brotbeck es ist das eine Thema dass das
Treffen der Ministerpräsidenten
dominieren wird wie weiter mit der
Zuwanderung die Reaktionen auf die
Vorschläge des Bundes gestern noch
halten den Ländern geht es vor allem um
Geld je mehr in das Land kommen je mehr
muss natürlich auch der Bund die Länder
und damit vor allem die Kommunen
unterstützen das jetzt auszutarieren da
ich nenne das mal eine eine ordentliche
gerechte Verteilung hinzubekommen das
wird jetzt in den nächsten Tagen auch
Aufgabe dieser Konferenz sein das zu
gestalten zunächst in noch getrennten
runden beraten die Länderchefs von SPD
und linker sowie von Union und Grünen
die Herausforderungen sind für alle
ähnlich Vorschläge wie Arbeitspflichten
für Asylbewerber umstritten umstritten
deshalb weil zur Zeit die Hürden dass
die Menschen die zu uns kommen sehr hoch
sind dass überhaupt Arbeit aufnehmen
können und deshalb ist meine absolute
oberste Priorität diese Hörden aus dem
Weg zu räumen die Menschen wollen der
Regel arbeiten und sie dürfen nicht
arbeiten und das muss geändert werden
und zwar sehr schnell am besten heute
durch einen Beschluss besonders drängend
für die Länder die Lage ihrer Kommunen
wir haben nicht die Liegenschaften die
Gebäude um sie unter zu bringen wir
haben nicht die Plätze in die Kitas wir
haben nicht das
Betreuungspersonal aber zumindestens
muss man schauen dass man es finanziert
bekommt das was man hat also das was der
Bund uns anbietet ist die Hälfte dessen
was wir benötigen mehr Geld vom Bund
darauf können sich die Länder
untereinander einigen mit dem Bund noch
lange
nicht vier Tage nach der landtagsw in
Bayern drücken CSU und Freie Wähler aufs
Tempo schon in der ersten
Sondierungsrunde einigten sich beide
Parteien darauf Koalitionsverhandlungen
aufzunehmen erste Arbeitsgruppen sollen
sich morgen treffen CSU und Freie Wähler
haben auch in den vergangenen fün Jahren
gemeinsam
regiert Wölfe waren in Deutschland schon
ausgerottet kamen dann wieder und
bereiten sich jetzt immer stärker aus
und das führt zu heftigem Streit aktuell
gibt's in ganz Deutschland über 180
Rudel und weil sich die Wölfe stark
vermehren ärgern sich darüber so einige
nutztierhalter die möchten ihr Vieh vor
Angriffen bewahren aber Wölfe stehen
unter besonderem Schutz das
Umweltministerium präsentierte jetzt
Vorschläge wie es mit diesem Dilemma
umgehen will dazu Annette
Pöschel wenn Silvia Krause zu ihren
ungarischen zackelschafen geht begleitet
sie oft ein mulmiges Gefühl ist alles in
Ordnung oder haben Wölfe wieder eins
ihrer Lämmchen geholt
50 Tiere hat sie bislang verloren trotz
Schutzzaun ich bin eigentlich nicht der
scharfhalter der die Schafe züchtet
damit die Wolfspopulation erhalten wird
seit der Wolf zur Jahrtausendwende nach
Deutschland zurückgekehrt ist breereitet
er sich immer weiter aus jedes Jahr
töten oder verletzen sie tausende
Weidetiere immer wieder wurden darum
Forderungen laut den Wolf schneller
schießen zu können genau das schlägt nun
auch Bundesumweltministerin Lempke Vorum
für die Wölfe die den Herdenschutz
überwinden bereits nach dem ersten Riss
können Wölfe 21 Tage lang im Umkreis von
1000 m von der betreffenden weideer ohne
dna- Test geschossen werden das gilt in
Regionen mit erhöhtem
rissvorkommen dem Deutschen
Bauernverband gehen diese Pläne nicht
weit genug mit solchen placebolösungen
wird die weidetierhaltung weiterhin
einer verfehlten und weltfremden pitik
geopfert Unterstützung dagegen vom
Naturschutzbund ganz besonders zu
betonen ist aber dass es hier nicht um
den Einstieg in eine generelle Bejagung
oder pauschale Abschussquoten von Wölfen
geht sondern um Einzelfälle in denen
Wölfe Weidetiere gerissen haben trotz
Herdenschutz wie bei Silvia Krause die
Schäferin hofft dass den Ankündigungen
nun auch schnell Taten
folgen tatenfolgen gutes
Stichwort deutschen
Fußballnationalspieler sind in den USA
und der Trainer versucht jetzt seine
Ideen umzusetzen ein stabiles Gerüst
soll her das ist se Devise un weit
entfernt von Boston formt Julian
nagelsmann seine Mannschaft die in den
bevorstehenden Länderspielen gegen die
USA und Mexiko Achtungszeichen setzen
soll dabei gibt der neben erfahrenen
Profis auch jungen Spielern eine
Chance in den taktischen und personellen
Planspielen des Bundestrainers nehmen
auch drei Neulinge eine wichtige Rolle
ein der Flügelstürmer vom VfB Stuttgart
Chris fürich der mit 32 Spätberufene
unionteorjäger Kevin Berenz und
Mittelfeldspieler Robert Andrich aus
Leverkusen alle drei hatten nicht mit
einer Nominierung gerechnet habe auch
ehrlicherweise so zwei drei Nächte
konnte ich nicht so gut einschlafen oder
allgemein nicht so gut schlafen weil man
wahrscheinlich so viel verarbeitet im
Kopf aber ich freue mich schon sehr sehr
macht sehr sehr viel Spaß ich f super
aufgenommen von der Mannschaft die
Trainingseinheiten machen sehr viel Spaß
und ja und ich freue mich auf die
nächsten Tage fühlt sich sehr sehr gut
an hier i zu sein die Nachricht bekommen
zu haben ja wie gesagt ich bin super
happy darüber nicht nur die neuen auch
die etablierten im Team wollen gegen die
USA mit stabilen Leistungen
überzeugen zwei deutsche Teams sind bei
den beachw Weltmeisterschaft in Mexiko
ausgeschieden die
DR Laura Ludwig und Luisa Lippmann sowie
Sandra itlingen und Karla Borger zwei
deutsche Duos sind aber auch weiter
stehen im
Achtelfinale ein beeindruckender Sieg
Schrei nach starker Leistung Sinja
Tillmann und Senja Müller hatten gegen
das spanische Duo Steine Soria nur im
ersten Satz zu kämpfen letztlich gab es
aber einen sicheren 22 Z20 und 21 Z1
Erfolg noch souveräner nels elers und
Clemens Wickler die Österreicher HL
Horst waren gegen das einzige deutsche
Männerteam bei dieser WM chancenlos 21
z12 und 21 z17 nach perfekter Vorrunde
jetzt auch der nie geefährdete Einzug
ins
Achtelfinale gespielt wird heute Nacht
Zeitverschiebung danke Christin
wetterverschiebung vielleicht bald
morgen noch mal extrem warm im Süden im
Norden stürmisch und was danach kommt
gleich von Katja horneffer um 21:45 Uhr
empfehlen wir das heute journal mit Anne
Gellinek so viel von uns danke und bis
[Musik]
morgen
guten Abend das nächste Tief bringt viel
Wärme Wind und viel Regen mit es zieht
bis morgen Abend über die Nordsee und
Dänemark weiter bis nach Südschweden
heute Nacht ist es bei uns meist bedeckt
und es fällt auch noch Regen dabei
bleibt es meist mild die Temperaturen
sinken auf 16 bis 10° nur im Nordosten
wird's bei 9 bis 6° schon kälter und
morgen breitet sich dann der Regen aus
das geht am Vormittag los über nordr
Westfalen dann erreicht der Regen auch
Niedersachsen Bremen Hamburg schisswig-
Holstein micklburg Vorpommern und
Brandenburg dann beruhigt sich die Lage
kurz aber zum späten Nachmittag und
Abend erwarten uns kräftige Schauer und
auch zum Teil Gewitter von Nordwesten
dazu drohen schwere sturmböhnen an der
Küste und Orkanböhen auf dem Brocken im
Harz von all dem bekommen sie ganz im
Süden nichts mit da strahlt Morgen die
Sonne und so können rekordverdächtige
30° erreicht werden mit föne am
alpenbrand oder auch im beißgau auch
sonst bleib es mild bis warm bei 18 bis
26° der Samstag wird dann schon sehr
wechselhaft am Sonntag könnte es im
Erzgebirge oberhalb von 800 m für nasse
Schneeflocken reichen am Montag
beschränken sich Regenschauer auf den
Nordosten guten Abend